the idea is that usually if you measure
the scores of anything temperatures
pipes wait exam results etc you're going
to have the mean you're going to have
all the scores cross it around the lead
but then there will be unusual
individuals who are either side really
really finally separate from the whole
body of everyone else okay and that's
how we describe what out lineup so if
you just want those miners your arms
peichi if you draw yourself like a
really rough sketch of what a set of
court could look like you might expect
any frequency graph to look something
like this by the way last time we
yesterday you have a look at some of
these shapes and their name called you
call this you could call it a bell curve
is a very common name a new shape turn
it upside down you can shape kind of
thing oh this is pretty symmetrical I've
been really nervous yeah in the middle
of course as you expect benjamini and
then maybe you get like a few kind
finish here Randy you're like what's
going on here right so you across these
guys which is getting an illusion you
class these guys out lies because they
fit 54 definitions technically you've
got them this is the big body scored and
then these guidance okay as you can
imagine this kind of definition only
takes you so far because it's informal
it's like the less I've got of millions
and millions of scores at which point do
I say these people are outliers or not
so that's why we introduce a more
mathematical mechanism supporters and
I'm actually going to show you thankful
if you I don't know if I'm this is
mention yesterday this is on the
reference sheet okay so not repre sheets
and formerly regarded I'll mathematical
formula for how to work out our line
starts with the interquartile range okay
she's made the interquartile range you
know what that number is so that's how
far apart what two things are worse
what a nerd in them yeah so this is you
can write this in future way you can say
q3 segue q1 or alternatively sometimes
instead of the three and the one what do
you see human yeah you've seen you and L
instead of three and one what did the
human be out there yeah i'm just going
to write that down okay so you've got a
nuke imagine from here you've got to
introduce it outlines you know people
who are bugged the main money and then
people Quran the Lord and you can access
both of it by taking this number and
seeing how they interact when these are
right so let's think about this if you
pull boy so this is outlier to up the
load obviously if you're below the me
well you expect like half the people to
be employed meet roughly so how far do
you need to be below the mean in order
to be caught and outlier you have been
pretty far right look you have to be
quite a distance away so what difference
is that we say if you are one and a half
time that interquartile range if you're
wondering this is the important number
if you're below the lower quartile by
that far so you will take away back
anything below this you say well that
must be an outliner down here the
interquartile rate is quite a broad
number so to be one and a half times
further away than the hopeful of means
okay example outliers that are above the
mean are exactly to save it in the
opposite direction so outliers above the
mean this means you're not just about
average you're really really above
average how one is of every day well
instead of starting from the lower
quartile and subtracting you're going to
go from the upper quartile and you're
going to add to go to further up what do
you think we're gonna add
I mean one of the first times the
interquartile range so as I just
mentioned this is not these two BR are
on this formula sheet so you don't need
to remember their numbers Leslie which i
think is helpful because the one the
half is trying to kind of arbitrary
people just decided well that's going to
give you a pretty good idea evolve when
you're too far or you're too okay so
okay qualitative so let's actually do
can we do an example I'm going to do
some data usage in calculate are ready
another one really notices Genesis is
not here okay I get you two sorted out
what were they the street called school
does the beginning their license 75 18
new people and six equal you guys add it
on and 95 I pink ok now we're going to
add on a few what's going to this
because at the moment there being only
full tours it's somewhat silly to talk
about quartiles right there's not much
of population here the quartiles are all
the very poor choice so each of those is
the quarter so let's have a few more
school loves it so they go a little more
interesting right the thing at the
moment is 80 it means AG so it wouldn't
be that surprised you the most of scores
are going to cost are around the ages
are we just a bit of energy for every
time you look exactly what that mean for
ya all right thank you so much what the
media is or is not there normal people
call of nice just to make it interesting
[Music]
okay there we go so let's go ahead
you've got a bit of a head start of me
so this [ __ ] can calculate off and
recall that a lot of foods we have the
calculator which will work out
interquartile range for you which is
very nice so let's will do that
[Music]
you talk about on beautiful all right
yeah cool okay your step ahead of me
anything fun yes yeah that's much less
playing okay so our minimum is Darla me
so severe this is what your matching is
this what you type of yes okay so just
check with gold line and make sure like
I've given you a smaller set of numbers
that we actually can just physically
thought of in and make sure that this
makes sense is what we're talking about
what's the smaller school looks like 60
then followed by a 64 are there any more
scores in the 60s no see move over to
the 70s 75 78 any more towards the
settings ok now we're going to budget
aes right so i think i gave you 80 1 80
to 85 87 and then 95 did I miss any
looks like it alright so let's just
quickly have a look because they're a
nice chord that's an odd number you can
work out what the media is very quickly
which one is the median out of nine
scores 81 it's going to be the fifth
gorgeous right in the middle so that guy
itself is the median you've got four
scores on the other side now can you see
how that works out what the upper
quartile and the low floor tiles are
defeated 86 where that dry in between 54
yes and what are 16 on the hub is that's
wrong yeah it'd be our means of 54 in 35
because that everything's checking out
we've just found it in port orange by
subtracting ok now I'm not just that
number idea question yes your day yeah
ok so if this is this man here in 16.5
ok I want to know what one and a half
times that's Spencer one half times the
interquartile range in equal to r1 in
person oh my god 20 half of these a
25-24 475 isn't it ok so in other words
what you've done is taken it
interquartile range and then you said
okay I got this further go a bit further
right we want to have a comparator what
these numbers hard with this gets done
ok sir attempted the lower quartile is
16 open bar so to subtract this you can
every five take away twinkle 475 that's
going to be 40 4.75 here 44.7 that
client low incidence which makes sense
it always been really an outlier you've
got to be quite far away from all these
guys here in exactly two a way I'm going
to revert it just upper quartile which
is going to and then I'm going to add 24
/ 7 / so that's going to be a hundred
and what their life yeah
not again now I didn't say what these
chords where they will just executed
representative this would mean that the
scores are certified you can't really
have an outline of our question this
definition because you can't there for
four hundred percent but that tells you
how far you need to give you your height
from some other type temperatures in our
minds maybe and that was tell you how
finally go to be classified as an
outlier okay so does that make sense to
do it's not hard to work out what each
of these numbers is and then just have
to know what some students understanding
on the Empire would be correct so I can
I denotes the question on any of these
chords outliers and I mean you could you
can look at the number to say what is
great time too high compared to the rest
of them but is nothing to high enough to
meet this this numerical standard for
too high and it's the same thing with 46
p it's not low enough to be nice if I've
scored are 23 you say okay this guy's so
much an outlier I put 43 you have MS D
are you saying well maybe we should
actually be normal him from part of the
data because most of the class is
clearly over here